was out cruise your first cruise that
you were ever on
no i went on this thing called semester
at sea it was like a floating school oh
wow that went around the whole world
actually
around the planet you how long was that
it was 100 days
and you and we i went i was a student i
worked in the bookshop
on the boat yeah
how old were you i was 19 years old i
know i was 20 years old so it was like
college yeah it was college
they still do it it's called semester at
sea and you go
and have you spoken about this before
i don't know if i've spoken much about
it i've never heard you really that's a
very
that's a very interesting crazy thing
you did it was crazy
so where did you go we started in
vancouver canada
and then we finished in florida we went
all the way around the whole world you
go around everywhere and you went to
class had homework yeah and then also
worked like your life was did you dock
yeah we would die how often did you dock
and you were able to five days or three
days or five nights or three nights we
would die okay japan china vietnam
malaysia
kenya brazil we went cuba dude we did it
are you serious yeah so let me ask you a
question what was the breakdown of like
how often you had to do schoolwork like
did you did you were you able to
maintain your focus and your studies too
or was it just like come on now like
everybody just like phoned it in and it
was just like caligula on it no you
couldn't phone it in you had to like it
was pretty the the teachers were pretty
harsh okay so you really had to really
do it you know so you really had to do
so you did you went to it was what was
your schedule like was it every day
every day class started i think at 8 00
a.m or 9 a.m i can't remember
every day
it would alternate except for days when
you're in port so when you were in the
port you could go do stuff and travel
and do whatever you wanted you just had
to be back when the ship left or you
could use the ship as hotel and stay at
hotel
okay so okay so you would you would also
have the option to go get a hotel off
the ship yeah for the days because i was
about to say how could you live for 100
days and not get a little in a little
like cruise room like that
yeah it would be crazy you had a
roommate in there and um wow
it was wow if you don't like your
roommate yeah
you suck
how was your roommate oh my roommate was
great dude my roommate was a great guy
ryan thomas you talked to him to this
day
he a few years after the ship he passed
away man he was doing basketball he went
to
some school up in the north california
mountains like that weed school what's
that weed school up there
chino or cheapo cheeto uh
not cheeto it's like
it's like a place where the kids all do
weed and everybody's growing weed and
eating weed people are made out of weed
people have little weed dolls and stuff
voodoo dolls even made out of weed it
sounds fantastic yeah i mean it sounds
like he died of a heart attack because
it was so amazing yeah
so anyway r.i.p brother so anyway he
passed away but um the cruz was it was
an unbelievable experience man i mean it
was just you know you were just you
could get two wines a night you got
tickets for wines and they have the bar
open you get two wines a night
but we had a guy on there that died bruh
during the cruise yeah this dude died we
were at sea for like 12 days or
something something happened he died and
they put him in the freezer
yeah
man i've heard of that so they put
they're going to do with them with the
pork loin baby you know what i'm saying
that's crazy but you know how he died
huh you know how he died i'm not sure
was that like
did that
were people just like oh [ __ ] somebody
died or were you like oh my god
like they said someone just died a
student died and is in the freezer oh it
was a sec this guy was a senior citizen
oh okay because he had a couple see
about nine seniors on there going to
college on the cruise yes some of them
would like
man that's like it's it takes somebody
to be like i'm gonna go back to college
as an adult is one thing that's already
tough then to be like i'm gonna go to
sea for a hundred days that's crazy
so he just died he couldn't hang bro did
they give him an honorary
uh discharge i don't know if we like put
him into the sea like they did with um
osama bin laden i don't know what they
did
i do remember we did a funeral for him
one day
whoa
i remember we did a funeral and people
dressed up and
we put flowers out into the um ocean and
stuff and the crews did a big circle
like that it was like a
oh my god i forgot about that crazy dude
i wish i knew his name mark i think in a
hundred days you could have multiple
relationships like did you have a mini
life within that hundred days yeah like
you got new friends knew this knew that
like you know what i'm saying oh yeah
there's people from like different
countries on there
it was crazy bro what made you do that
like was that expensive
i'm fascinated because i've never heard
of this yeah it's called semester i see
it wasn't that it was ex uh
i it wasn't that expensive man i mean i
worked and saved up so many i had to
spend like 6 thousand of my own dollars
so yes that was a lot of money yeah but
i worked you know to to do it and then i
got financial aid from my school so that
applied to it okay and then a friend um
the i got a scholarship from the school
okay itself from the semester at sea wow
so i was really supported you know
i definitely
you know i was grateful that people
helped me oh yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you